he may not be as famous as J Robert
Oppenheimer but Enrico fermi's
experiments are what led to the creation
of the atomic bomb
growing up in Rome his brightness caught
the attention of his father's colleague
Railway engineer Adolfo amide who guided
him and taught him far more about math
and physics than he was learning in high
school had he not nurtured the 13 year
old Enrico history may have turned out
differently by the time Enrico entered
University in 1918 to study Physics at
the prestigious squala normale Superior
and Pisa there really wasn't anything
more his professors could teach him so
he spent a lot of time studying quantum
physics and relativity on his own he was
thoroughly impressed with Einstein's
special theory of relativity
particularly his equation E equals m c
squared which shows that mass and energy
are different forms of the same thing in
that a small amount of mass can be
converted into a large amount of energy
as a student he wrote if we could
Liberate the energy in one gram of
matter we would get more energy than
exerted by a thousand horses working
continuously over three years an
explosion of such an awesome amount of
energy would blow to Pieces the
physicist who had the misfortune of
finding a way to produce it these words
were prophetic given his later work
developing the deadliest weapon known to
humankind
after studying in Pisa he went off to
the University of godingen in Germany
where the Italian was overlooked by his
counterparts Marie Curie apparently
ignored him to the point of exceeding
rudeness according to a future colleague
of his on the Manhattan Project to build
the bomb as he had done in Pisa he
focused on probability theory in Germany
his Mastery of probability allowed him
to make accurate predictions with
minimal data a vital piece in figuring
out how to create the atomic bomb
according to biographer David Schwartz
fermi's interest in probability Theory
may have been sparked by the death of
his beloved brother Julia who died
during an operation on a throat abscess
at just 15 years old Schwartz surmises
Fermi may have taken away from this
trauma the need to understand the
likelihood of any particular event and a
feeling that in understanding that
probability he was in a better position
to anticipate it prepare for it and
perhaps even shape its outcome his set
of guidelines called Fermi Dirac
statistics developed in tandem with
English physicist Paul Dirac rely on the
use of probabilistic reasoning to
predict the energy levels of particles
called fermions imagine particles are
concert goers and their energy levels
are seats just as each person has a
unique seat each particle has a unique
energy level just as no two people can
share a seat no two particles can share
the same energy level his development of
Fermi Dirac statistics propelled him
from his job teaching at the University
of Florence to a prestigious physician
at the University of Rome where he
became Italy's first professor of
theoretical physics he sought to
establish Rome as a leading Center of
physics and was a natural leader others
gravitated toward in the Italian Capital
he developed his explanation of beta
Decay a process where unstable atoms
break down and emit a specific type of
radiation Fermi proposed that inside
these decaying atoms one of the neutrons
is turning into a proton when this
happens the neutron releases an electron
in a tiny almost massless particle
called a neutrino although this Theory
solidified his reputation as a leading
physicist it was his later experiments
developing the atomic bomb that
catapulted him into the Limelight he
built on the work of Marie Curie and her
husband Pierre who discovered that
bombarding substances with tiny
particles called alpha particles can
make them radioactive inspired by the
curies Fermi did something similar using
neutrons and discovered that certain
elements bombarded with neutrons also
become radioactive Fermi thought he had
created new elements he even won the
Nobel Prize in physics in 1938 for this
discovery but what he had actually done
was split uranium atoms a process that
is fundamental to the making of an
atomic bomb he didn't realize it because
he thought the nucleus of a uranium atom
was like a solid brick wall incapable of
changing shape it wasn't until German
physicists replicated his experiments
five years later that they made a
Monumental Discovery they realized
firing neutrons at uranium splits the
uranium atom a process called nuclear
Vision this releases an enormous amount
of energy which is fundamental to
nuclear weapons
Fermi found out about his embarrassing
Overlook after he moved to America in
1939 fascist Italy had become
intolerable by then Fermi had actually
joined the fascist party earlier as it
was common for career advancement
however as Hitler pressed Mussolini to
Target Italian Jews there was fear that
his wife Laura who was Jewish would be
persecuted another incentive to leave
his homeland was that the physicist and
politician Orso Mario corbino who had
guided his career and opened doors for
him had died suddenly from pneumonia
after corbino's death funding for his
research began to dry up Fermi took the
opportunity of collecting his Nobel
Prize at the awards ceremony in
Stockholm to then quietly head to New
York with his wife and two young
children where position awaited him at
Columbia University two weeks after
arriving in America on January 2nd 1939
he learned about the major discovery of
nuclear fission that he should have made
but there was no time to dwell on missed
opportunities and besides the process of
fission was not fully understood he
joined forces with another recent
American immigrant Hungarian physicist
Leo silard to understand and control
each step of the Chain Reaction process
they aimed to harness the enormous
amount of energy liberated within a
fraction of a second opening up the
possibility that uranium could be used
for power generation or potentially to
build a bomb
they were aware of the implications of
their work in light of the escalating
tensions that would eventually lead to
World War II and inform the U.S Navy the
dean of Graduate Studies at Columbia
George Pegram sent a letter to Admiral
Stanford Hooper outlining the potential
consequences of fermi's research this
might mean the possibility that uranium
might be used as an explosive that would
liberate a million times as much energy
per pound as any known explosive my own
feeling is that the probabilities are
against this but my colleagues and I
think the bare possibility should not be
disregarded the U.S Navy gave Fermi a
small fifteen hundred dollar Grant to
continue his work the government's
interest in fermi's research only
intensified after sealard wrote a letter
to President Roosevelt clearly spelling
out that extremely powerful bombs of a
new type May thus be constructed he
warned that Nazi Germany was
demonstrating a keen interest in uranium
research hinting at their pursuit of a
nuclear weapon the most famous scientist
Exile Albert Einstein signed the letter
to give it extra clout the US government
would eventually spend 2.2 billion to
build the first atomic bomb scientists
had to figure out how much uranium would
be needed to create a bomb and how to
assemble the bomb in such a way that it
would explode properly J Robert
Oppenheimer oversaw the Manhattan
Project coordinating the many teams who
worked on different aspects of the
bomb's development
the Manhattan Project was so secretive
that most staff had no idea what they
were working on Fermi was primarily
responsible for developing the first
nuclear reactor which demonstrated that
a nuclear Chain Reaction could be
initiated in control
by then he had moved from Colombia to
the University of Chicago at the request
of the U.S government which wanted to
consolidate all the nuclear research
projects across the country on December
2 1942 he and his team conducted a
nuclear experiment beneath the
University of Chicago's abandoned
football field in the squash court area
it was the only space with high enough
ceilings to allow the construction of
the pile of bricks of graphite and
uranium carefully arranged to facilitate
a reaction the graphite slowed down the
speed of the neutron so that they could
cause further fissions this Atomic
furnace called Chicago pile 1
demonstrated the First self-sustained
Chain Reaction ushering in the nuclear
age when Fermi realized the reaction was
self-sustaining quote his whole face
broke into a broad smile describe David
Schwartz in his biography on Fermi a
member of fermi's Team recorded the
moment in a log book writing were
cooking the team shared a bottle of wine
to Mark the occasion by the didn't make
any toasts this wasn't really A
celebratory moment as they knew the
implications of what they had achieved
the Chicago pile was a predecessor to
the giant nuclear reactors at Hanford
Washington
the U.S government acknowledges fermi's
pivotal role in creating the bomb
declaring more than any individual he
was responsible for developing a means
for the controlled release of nuclear
energy yet Oppenheimer has gotten far
more credit than Fermi one reason is
that Fermi rarely appeared on TV and he
wasn't into self-promotion and he also
passed away before television became
widespread on the other hand Oppenheimer
was often interviewed and photographed
as the leader of the Manhattan Project
Oppenheimer recognized and acknowledged
fermi's contributions in intellect at a
dinner party after fermi's death
Manhattan Project physicist leono Libby
recalled that Oppenheimer suggested a
game he called who do you want to be on
your day off and then he chose Fermi in
1944 Fermi moved to Los Alamos New
Mexico the main hub for the Manhattan
Project where he became an associate
director he served as an advisor
offering advice to other scientists when
they ran into problems on July 16 1945
scientists detonated the first nuclear
device near Alamogordo New Mexico Fermi
made a rough calculation of its
explosive energy by dropping small
pieces of paper as the Shockwave arrived
and estimated from their deflection that
the test had released energy equivalent
to ten thousand tons of TNT the actual
result was more than twice that amount
21 000 tons this is enough to power 2
million American homes for a year
the Trinity device Unleashed at
Alamogordo had a plutonium core which
Fermi and his team achieved through a
series of Transformations with uranium
that resulted in the creation of the
human-made element this design was later
replicated in one of the two devastating
bombs dropped on Japan
we don't know how Fermi reacted to the
bombing of Hiroshima and Nagasaki and
the hundreds of thousands of people who
perished instantly or who later died
from injuries in radiation sickness he
kept his emotions to himself what we can
glean is that during the development of
the bomb Oppenheimer recalled Fermi was
surprised by the group's enthusiasm for
building such a weapon and remarked I
believe our people actually want to make
a bomb
fermi's sister Maria did hold strong
views and wrote to her brother all
however are perplexed and appalled by
its Dreadful effects and with time the
bewilderment increases rather than
diminishes for my part I recommended you
to God who alone can judge you morally
after the war Fermi opposed working on
the hydrogen bomb which is orders of
magnitude more powerful than the atomic
bomb on moral and Technical grounds
though he still contributed as
consultant the detonation of an atomic
bomb by the Soviet Union in 1949 sparked
Washington's interest in a more powerful
weapon Oppenheimer strongly resisted
working on a hydrogen bomb and faced
hearings that questioned his loyalty
suspecting him to be a Soviet spy
despite Fermi and other scientists
coming to his defense Oppenheimer had
his security clearance revoked
Fermi went on to become a distinguished
professor of physics at the University
of Chicago where he was regarded as a
superb teacher during his later years he
raised an interesting question while
lunching with colleagues where is
everybody he was asking why no
extraterrestrial civilizations had been
discovered despite the great size and
age of the universe this is referred to
as a Fermi Paradox because it's an
apparent contradiction between the high
probability of the existence of aliens
due to the vast number of stars that can
potentially host habitable planets and
the lack of human contact with such
civilizations or evidence for them
fermi's view was that if intelligent
life existed elsewhere in the universe
we should have been visited by them long
ago while Fermi contemplated the
vastness of the universe a more
immediate personal concern soon cast a
shadow over his life his health had
started to decline in the summer of 1954
he was noticeably fatigued he visited
the doctor that fall and they discovered
he had stomach cancer that had
metastasized he was given six months to
live
throughout his career Fermi was exposed
to radioactive materials which may have
contributed to the development of his
cancer
Fermi was not a religious person but as
he lay ill and dying he received visits
from priests his Manhattan Project
colleague Lionel Libby who frequently
went to see him recalled he spoke of his
approaching death as a great experience
what he asked wishfully if I thought
there was anything valid in the idea of
an afterlife he was really cross about
dying I came out after each visit and
drove home with tears streaming down my
face
his condition deteriorated rapidly two
months after his diagnosis on November
28 1954 Enrico Fermi passed away at his
home he was 53 years old
in an obituary the New York Times wrote
more than any other man of his time
Enrico Fermi could properly be named the
father of the atomic bomb
fermi's contributions touch our lives
beyond the realm of physics tech
companies are known to ask candidates
complex problems during job interviews
to see if they can emulate fermi's way
of thinking an example of a Fermi
problem would be estimating the number
of piano tuners in a city like Toronto
Toronto has a population of
approximately 3 million people if we
assume an average of Two and a Half
people per household this gives us 1.2
million households let's say one out of
50 homes in Toronto has a piano that
means that there are 24 000 pianos in
the city they're usually tuned once a
year so there are 24 000 piano tunings
required per year let's see a piano
tuner takes two weeks of vacation a year
so they work 50 weeks a year let's say
they tune two pianos a day times five
days a week that means that in one year
one piano theater can tune 500 pianos so
if there are 24 000 tunings a year
divided by 500 tunings per tuner there
is a need for 48 piano tuners in Toronto
it's this kind of curious mindset that
brilliant aims to cultivate in Learners
of all ages I really enjoy Brilliance
logic puzzles that help sharpen my
analytical thinking brilliant offers a
Hands-On interactive approach for all of
its science technology engineering and
math courses my viewers really love
Brilliance computer science courses that
can help you stay ahead in today's
competitive Marketplace there's
something for everyone whether you're a
beginner or you're interested in
progressing through their more advanced
courses you can try out brilliant for
free for 30 days with my custom link
brilliant.org newsthink the link is in
my description in the first 200 people
who sign up with my custom link will get
20 off your premium subscription which
gives you access to all the offerings
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm